in a perfect world we'd want government
support and a lot more of it that would
exist now why though the marketplace
can't take care of everything it's
subject to the whims and the caprices of
sponsors who want to change things when
you wake up at 3:00 in the morning and
your house is on fire you don't call the
marketplace let's talk a little bit
about your broader kind of worldview in
a 1998 speech you talked about why you
are a yellow dog Democrat what what does
that mean or what do you mean by that
and how does that influence your work
you know I work is without political
advocacy or political I I'm trying to
speak to as many people as possible I
happen to have born into a family of
Democrats and Kennedy for our viewers
who are not familiar with what a yellow
that yellow dog democrat is sort of a
democrat for life and and that was just
you know the expression that you add i
would have voted for abraham lincoln who
knows if it had been the 1860s that i
would have been a yellow dog republican
in that regard but that just is the
circumstances of my birth my job is to
tell a good story to tell it well until
it fairly and so the films are
attracting everybody you know there's
some people who are into political
adverts key that don't make a single
convert they preach to the converted
they teach to the choir and and that's
what it is and that's a perfectly
legitimate thing I want to reach as many
people as possible and I do on both
sides of the proverbial aisle and my
politics are in some ways irrelevant
other than the fact that I'm sure it
influences responses as I do it but we
work awfully hard and work with people
of different political persuasions to
just tell films that are general and to
[ __ ] I mean I we have lost this ability
to have a civil discourse and history is
still a table around which we can agree
to have that civil conversation I don't
know anybody that doesn't like Abraham
Lincoln it isn't drawn to his notion of
a certified friends of our nation yes
well you know arguably more than anybody
over the past generation or two you've
revitalized documentary filmmaking
documentary storytelling history you
know taking a rich interest in history
and really
mainstreaming with it how what explains
the your success and appeal is it that
you seek to go beyond the kind of using
history to to beat people over the head
well I think sometimes history is used
as a kind of propaganda tool or a
superficial sanitized Madison Avenue
celebration of you know the goodness of
America and the good old days and I'm
clearly not interested in that I would
suggest that documentaries have been
undergoing Renaissance for many many
decades and they manifest in so many
different ways to make one or two or
three people responsible is not the case
we've just been laboring in one area in
which we saw that the telling of history
need not be castor-oil it didn't have to
be the dry recitation of dates facts and
events stuff you should know the last
time I checked that was homework but
rather realizing that the word history
is mostly made up of the word story to
tell complicated and dramatic stories
that oh you know that that obey the same
laws as stories told anywhere feature
films are governed by the same laws and
we've done that and people have
responded it by the tens of millions and
that's thrilling who are your primary
influences as a filmmaker and as a
historian well I'm not a historian I'm
an amateur historian the last time I
took a course in American history was
until eleventh grade you know where they
hold a gun to your head and make you
take it I'm a filmmaker and my
influences are why they're still
photographers social documentary still
photographers like my mentor Jerome
Liebling and Paul strand and Walker
Evans and Henri cartier-bresson and
Dorothea Lange they're our filmmakers of
the pantheon of great world filmmakers
and in drama and the Scorsese's in
America the Orson Welles in America
Buster Keaton Charlie Chaplin and Alfred
Hitchcock John Ford Frank Capra but
they're also other documentary
filmmakers I may not have that stylistic
similarity with an arrow Morris but you
can't help but admire the genius of his
stylism
and you know I like Verner Hertzog who
is not only a friend but I think a
passionate almost ecstatic filmmaker
that has these operatic takes on the
world and I always enjoy though I I
don't work in that same way where you
are where did your kind of aesthetic
sensibility come from because it's
remained you know recognizable over time
style is essentially the authentic
application of technique every person
who's an artist has a style and if you
just change for the sake of change
you're probably not an artist you're
somebody following the fashions of the
time so if you go into a room of Cezanne
paintings they all look like from the
middle the same you go up to each one
and they're different so that you
recognize a stylistic similarity in my
films but only because it's me trying to
express myself but each film has its own
unique and diverse sets of criteria I
grew up with a father who is an
anthropologist and an amateur still
photographer for my first memory is that
great alchemy of watching a photograph
come to life in a darkroom my teachers
at school were not only filmmakers but
social documentary still photographers
I'm rooted in that thing but I'm also
rooted in writing and a kind of
humanists tradition of American history
that includes not just the old top-down
version but a bottom-up version that
acknowledges women and labor and
minorities and other people so-called
ordinary people in the rush of history
and that American history isn't just a
sequence of presidential administrations
punctuated by war if you if you're
willing to embrace a much wider and more
diverse history then it's more
complicated and if it's more complicated
than you have to lift up the rug of
history and show warts you have to have
undertow and be able to tolerate that
undertow and the contradictions that
attend any one great or so-called
ordinary and and I think that's been the
work for the last 35 years to go back to
PBS should PBS be taxpayer-funded you're
early
it's just now well let me let me ask
your current project it's underwritten
by PBS or Corporation for Public
Broadcasting some nonprofit foundations
as well as the Bank of America
you could get funding for your projects
that's not true
upwards of 40% of my project come from
some governmental source or another PBS
is not exactly governmental it is
actually not governmental but it gets
some money from the government and they
give us money usually we'll subscription
stuff but the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting is a significant funder and
quite often the National Endowment for
the Humanities are in a perfect world
we'd want government support and a lot
more of it that would exist now why they
would because the marketplace the
marketplace can't take care of
everything it's subject to the whims and
the caprices of sponsors who want to
change things when you wake up at 3:00
in the morning and your house is on fire
you don't call the marketplace you are
not expecting the marketplace to protect
you after 9/11 and while I don't mean to
suggest that public television has
anything to do let me finish with the
defense of this country it helps make
the country worth defending because it
has a set of people operating free of
those pressures of the marketplace and
it just so happens that they produce
some of the best children's some of the
best science some of the best nature's
some of the best arts some of the best
public performance some of the best
public affairs and some I'm told some of
the best history on the dial that's not
so bad with one foot in the marketplace
and the other tentatively out and I have
dedicated myself not just to working
there where I have creative freedom and
free of commercial interruptions but
because I believed in the idea of
service and the exchange television is a
passive medium that washes over us and
puts us to sleep and this offers us the
opportunity when people looked at our
National Park film 10 million of them
got up off the couch and went to visit a
national but what I'm saying though is
it's not a question of whether or not
you can get money from the government
and do good things with it but is that
the best way to fund because it's
probably the best-known independent
producer in public television or let's
just say one of the best-known yeah we
are in the most difficult economic
circumstances and I am I've gone from
fundraising 25 percent of my time to 75
percent of the time I could run for
Congress but that is the the the
government stuff is held firm if I lost
that I would be out of this but I mean
is that a problem for taxpayers to solve
yeah but I mean that it is you know I
mean from taxpayers itself we're the
only developed and industrialized
country that spends almost zero on arts
and humanities if you can include that
but well from the government because in
terms of actual philanthropic giving we
give tens of billions of dollars a years
and I've let me ask this you know so the
marketplace or funders in nonprofits or
from the marketplace put strings on
creative control or the projects they
fund but there's no similar there is no
similar your projects that funded solely
on the merits yes as opposed to from the
nonprofit's that might also fund your
work I mean what I'm saying is I I have
a portion of the funders and none of
them exert any including mine private
business exactly right so we can't but
that's the nature of public television
not the nature of private businesses if
I had a funder that was from the
marketplace in America if they were
funding your movie fully they would
exert pressure because it's a hobby they
could they could fund me fully in public
television and they could exert no
pressure
in other words Errol Morris does not
seem to labor under either a great need
for public funding or a lot of corporate
control but he also works a great deal
of his time doing commercial work on the
side which I don't have the time or the
luxury or the talent I mean I'm not sure
this is I mean it's an interesting topic
it's a great debate but I've spent 30
years realizing how lucky I am because
there is public broadcasting it is
incredibly difficult
I could easily if I jump to some other
market fully marketplace enjoy many
picture deals but they would own it they
could control it ever and and the and
the real proof of it is to watch the the
arc of my professional life and see that
at every time without naming names
groups came to me and said what are you
working on or I would go to groups I say
I'm doing 11 and a half hours of still
photographs on the Civil War and they
laughed me out of their office then when
it was the highest-rated program in the
history of PBS they came to me what are
you doing next said I'm doing a sequel
to the Civil War oh that's great what is
it a history of baseball
okay how long is it 18 and a half hours
laughed me out of the office when that
had even higher viewership than the
Civil War they came to me what are you
doing next they said the history of jazz
and they said african-american stuff
doesn't sell so I got to do the work
that I wanted to do that anyway rejoice
and you wouldn't be able to do that
through HBO
well III because don't be they would
still own it they would still control
there would be a boss above but the
limit of the argument then you're saying
the taxpayer is giving you free money to
do things and we don't get anything back
from that in terms I've paid back my
grants 100% if McDonnell Douglas did
that for the defense contractors our
budget would be a different thing but I
received 1 million three hundred and
forty nine thousand five hundred dollars
from the National Endowment for
Humanities and the first money that the
Civil War owned went received went to
pay that back in full so the people of
the United States have been made whole
so what's the question this government
as John Adams said he said I study war
and politics so that my son might study
Commerce and Industry so that my
grandchildren might study art and music
the whole purpose of the United States
was the foster what Jefferson thought in
the end the pursuit of happiness was not
a hedonistic pursuit of things in a
marketplace of objects but a lifelong
pursuit of Education which the only
thing on the dial that seems to be
dedicated this and I would ask you to go
and look at what the arts and
entertainment network is doing or what
the Discovery Network is doing or what
the History Channel is which has to do
HBO is a wonderful wonderful oasis
within that but still with regard to
control and whatever and the History
Channel because of the addiction to
commercials can only go this deep before
they have to tell you the hook that's
going to keep you hopefully watching to
the next one and then the next dive is
even less deep because they have to
remind you where they've been and tell
you where the next
and briefly by talking about I mean you
talk about owning things and being able
to you know control the distribution in
that only but just but but really having
creative right well I mean but we're
also which is you know obviously every
artist every producer every director
every writer wants that and it's it's
hard to maintain in the best of
circumstances we live in a world where
there are proliferating outlets where
there are copyright laws regardless of
whatever their intentions are there
their stated policies are are harder and
harder to enforce is this a good time
for cultural expression or do you find
it chaotic too are you worried about
where where are the films going to come
from where they where's the capital etc
how are you feeling about I feel living
in a proliferating world
I feel pretty optimistic I think it is
chaotic and chaos causes anxiety and you
don't really know particularly with
ownership and copyright audience you
know I've gone through we're selling 60
millimeter prints for nine hundred
dollars to libraries was a viable thing
and libraries had budgets to buy several
films a year and then we went to u-matic
and then to VHS and those went down in
price to two DVDs and there seemed to be
a marketplace and now it's all downloads
and or getting to be all download so
there's a kind of anxiety about changing
things but but this proliferation of
equipment the proliferation of platforms
and outlets can only be a good thing the
biggest problem is the fragmentation
that when I grew up there were four or
five channels and people basically
shared a common canon of knowledge and
awareness of the world now people can
seek their own self satisfying sources
and that's huge those hugely dangerous
let's say there are suggesting on trees
in Europe and people you know it was
good to keep people there or is it good
to allow them to emigrate where that's
the completely unappropriate analogy
what I'm saying that if you're a country
of 250 million when I was growing up and
there were five outlets three you know
national nightly news people knew more
or less the same thing
now if you're conservative and you and
you get all your information from Fox or
you're a liberal you get all your
information from MSNBC you are self
selecting the information you're getting
you may not be aware of the stuff that
the general broadcast had and people can
then develop misconceptions the lies can
not only go around the world three or
four times before the truth gets started
but you can actually labor under
falsehoods either left or right and the
moment of falsehoods more just as a kind
of widespread in a world of Walter
Cronkite know and Brinkley and Huntley
and more pernicious because there was
only the official story no no not at all
and they weren't giving the official
story what they were struggling to do
was adhering to concepts of balance and
journalism that have basically
disappeared certainly within the cable
world in which its advocacy now there's
is something very good about hearing
somebody who is Marxist or fascist had
to understand that but what we found is
that people tend to gravitate to what is
self satisfying and that's a dangerous
thing to hear only what you want to hear
is not to be exposed to the truth for
example with the war in Vietnam in which
Walter Cronkite who bent over backwards
in and his network of rant over
backwards with probably the most storied
tradition of excellence in journalism
came to the painful realization that
that something was going wrong and and
and that was a startling thing for
people to wake up and serve something
like the Iraq war though where you have
mainstream outlets such as the New York
Times and ABC News essentially just
carrying water for the administration it
was these alternative I don't
characterize it is that I know what
you're referring to and of course that's
shameful moments when people make
mistakes will always remain Haitian
that's exactly because you know I think
you're trying to fit something in that
doesn't quite fit mistakes will always
be made humans will always be
susceptible to persuasion but when you
are addicted to one particular point of
view and that's all you show if you are
absolutely certain that this person is
Satan and that's all that your thing
does and this person happens not to be
Satan or a god and this person happens
not to be God then if
you're actually not let already you're
not letting me finish the sentence but
I'd like to complete that if it is those
extremes rule and dominate then you have
no chance to actually understand that
the nature of human life is itself a
complicated dichotomous thing that goes
back to what we were talking about that
we are both generous and greedy that we
are both Puritan and period that we are
both sincere and hypocritical that we
both listen and we interrupt
I often accused of being better in the
interruption side is that a fair
depiction of say Fox News and MSNBC that
they are they demonize and that they
know because I think the superficiality
of what we've just been talking about
just the are just the nature of our
conversation right now requires that
everything gets reduced to a shorthand
Fox is never this one I mean you've
worried about fragmentation of audience
partly because people seek out
self-satisfying sources of information
or cultural identity and I guess I'm
questioning that or is it that they're
actually seeking out something that is
not self satisfying in a negative way
but is it in an expresso which is a
really good question and I travel the
country and I see more of the example of
the negative influence of that I see the
narrowness of viewpoints left or right
and you know the Latin motto of the
United States is a plural bassoon amout
of many one Arthur Schlessinger jr. the
late historian used to say that we
suffer today from too much pluribus and
not enough unum I'm in the business of
unum and so when you kind of go out and
see the extent to which pluribus has
taken over that you that we no longer
share experiences in common except in
the most dramatic moments like 9/11
really brings all of a sudden there's
there's MSNBC and Fox are
indistinguishable that's actually a
positive and good moment and it shows
that people kind of yearn for a sense of
community and connection despite the
fact that the proliferation of all these
sources does offer this cornucopia of
options which are terrific one of the
negative aspects and they're always that
everything has every knife has another
edge to it are these sort of pernicious
you know distractions into in the case
of a political discussion going but but
one can't label it all bad or all good
with the MSNBC Fox model they're
complicated dynamics within themselves
as well and and that's what the it's so
limiting for us to sort of dispense with
them with the label of left to right
because it is much more dynamic that's
why I find staying something that tries
to see a broader view that understands
distinct distinct perspectives helps you
in the long run and I guess to bring it
back to Prohibition I mean this is one
of the things that your series does is
that it complicates the idea that
prohibition was all going one way or the
other
that's right well with that because you
pointed out there were all these various
factions left and right you know black
and white that were for it and I think
you know we woke up to that in the
middle of it it was too easy to dismiss
this as purely a retrograde conservative
attempt to pull the country back to some
good old days that had never existed it
was a much more complicated dynamic a
genuine concern for the toll of alcohol
and ability on the part of the United
States to always think not naive not
just naively it was naive but also
sincerely that you could correct the
ills of society through legislation and
that that appealed a broad number of
people sometimes with nefarious things I
mean the Ku Klux Klan wanted it because
the worst thing in the world was to see
a black man with not just the ballot but
now a bottle and that would turn them
into beasts and it represented the worst
kind of racism but on the other hand
Booker T Washington wanted it because he
thought alcoholism distracted from black
advancement and so what do you do with
that other than to look at it as
phenomena and kind of an equal weight
and and go forward and try to understand
the crazy insanity that prohibition was
final question do you have a next
project oh I've got seven films in
various anybody's sure oh yeah oh yeah I
can't understand why filmmakers always
say well I can't really talk about this
project we've just finished editing a
film on the history of the Dust Bowl
we're completing a film in editing on
the Central Park jogger case
those five black and Hispanic boys
accused of Wilding serve their full
sentences didn't do it we've done it we
have a major series on the history of
the Roosevelts we're shooting right now
a film on Jackie Robinson we're shooting
right now a major series on Vietnam
we're in research and pre-production on
a series on the history of country music
and we're designing a biography on
Ernest Hemingway which will take us
through this decade sorry God and
funding willing I'm not sure I believe
in either of those more power to you for
a reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie we've
been talking with documentarian Ken
Burns whose latest project is
prohibition thanks again thank you
you